farmers at this pomegranate field in the
southern region of Ika are back at work
Harvest time is near and the fruit is
ready to be picked protesters have been
keeping them from reaching the fields
threatening to beat them it's been
difficult to work during the almost two
months of unrest following the oustino
former president Pedro Castillo Luz
Camacho says she's lost one quarter of
her wages enough to pay her monthly
debts to the bank
it has affected us a lot because we
haven't worked and we have loans and we
have debts where else are we gonna get
an income
transport in the South was at a virtual
standstill until the police and army
finally moved in
but the damage to key Industries has
been enormous icas Chamber of Commerce
says the region has lost 300 million
dollars since the crisis begun in
December
workers have been stepping up the pace
to make up for the time lost here
packing fruit to ship to Europe Canada
and the U.S director Jose Luis querida
buys nearly 70 percent of his exports
from small producers he says he's
concerned for the future of hundreds of
families
this political crisis is turning into a
social and economic crisis because if we
stop people will lose their income and
can't pay their debt Ika is connected to
the capital Lima along a major highway
which is also used to transport minerals
and petrol about 4.5 percent of the
country's GDP comes from this area the
finance ministry says Peru has lost more
than one half billion dollars and
there's been zero investment in the
South since Tina boluarte became
president in December
this is the third time Security Forces
lift locates in this area of the
Pan-American Highway since December and
they're still here guarding the area it
just shows how difficult the situation
is here and nothing guarantees it won't
happen again
that's why guillermakuri fears the worst
for his small farm
I don't know how long we will be in this
situation if protests continue we are
going to lose our products everything
many here believe this truth is only
temporary because once the security
forces are gone it's just a matter of
time before protesters block the road
again Mariana sanchezida